the Dare says we want it to be at the
window to the future what we're trying
to do is change the prosthetics industry
so we can offer affordable functional
and beautiful prosthetic devices to
altitudes
I'm proud of being one-handed it doesn't
make me feel any different but wearing
this instead of having people come up to
me or give me like this sincere look
oh you've lost your arm they go oh wow
this is fantastic and it may I just like
to see people to have a smile on their
face about it that's what it's all about
for me because we're heavily promoting
this kind of technology some people
really think like we were producing you
know augmented arms and you know some
fans or some moms and so on we're asking
where can I buy you on and unfortunately
we have to say we're not building any
arms with just a video game company but
that triggers you know the thing where
we say we should do something
was a really natural fit when they got
in touch with us we were almost
expecting it at some point and we formed
this idea to try and turn Adam Jensen
Psalm into a real-life bionic limb I was
actually born my left hand so I've never
seen any different and I've always
wanted to have like a robot I can I've
never said I wanted two hands just a
robotic one just to feel more cyborg
because it's just so much cooler
especially being into sci-fi and comics
and stuff I developed the first Bionic
hand when I was 17 just tinkering in my
bedroom at my parents house when I was
younger so when I went to university a
few years later I wanted to take the
project a little bit further and found
that Bionic hands existed for amputees
to wear but they were extremely
expensive and so I used that angle
that's an excuse to be allowed to create
a Bionic hand for my final year project
at university and then after university
was when I co-founded open bionics and
we began working on the same problem
with a more kind of definitive goal of
being able to offer these Bionic hands
to people at a really affordable price
so this is a custom-built one for myself
we use sensors in the top and bottom of
my arm so if I tense my bottom muscles
it will close and if I loosen up but
tense upwards slightly it'll open we
have a fantastic art director his name
is Jonathan Jack Valdez this guy is a
vision he's completely crazy and the way
we wanted to depict you know a future
world was that human augmentations
couldn't be like just medical device we
wanted it to be super rewarding you know
people are wearing these kind of
processes in a fashionable way
for their sex we never wanted to do some
give me keep big robots hand and so on
we wanted something to touch upon you
know the high fashion very refined
design something that looks very sleek
and very you know you could be very
proud to wear it and then you can change
all the functions like that kind of cool
at this point we've made a semi
functional prototype so we've made one
that's functional and looks similar to
Adam Johnson's hand the next steps for
us will be perfecting the functionality
of it so that it works really nicely and
it's very good at grasping objects and
then making the finish really nice so
that it looks the part as well the
design files that we're working on in
this project will be open sourced as
well so people will be able to download
them they have a 3d printer they'll be
able to make themselves an Adam Jensen
arm that will be functional and they'll
be able to use it
we don't want to cut this technology
this accessibility to people who have
their both hands and so on so we
partnered with Intel with the realsense
division and Razer with their stargazer
division also multiple points on the
hand in motion it's captured in
real-time
the result is a one-to-one mirroring
between even uses hand and a bionic hand
we want to show limb different people
that the products and devices that
they're seeing in science fiction and
gaming and in movies can become reality
and can become reality very soon it's
mind blowing for a lot of people but I
cannot wait for the future of this
everything we're doing is somehow a new
step forward we now defining the future
you